so as a brief outline of what i'm going
to talk with you about today
first i'm going to introduce some of the
different anatomic sites that are
available for blood collection in mice
and i'll then discuss some of the
factors that affect
the impact that these particular
phlebotomy methods can have on a mouse
and ways that we can assess or quantify
the impact of phlebotomy on mice
i'll then talk about how your phlebotomy
site choice as an experimenter can
actually impact your study data
and i'll then discuss how the phlebotomy
choice can actually
impact the performer themselves and how
the performer skill
can potentially differentially impact
the success of the different phlebotomy
techniques
i'll then talk about some of the
difficulties that exist when we're
trying to compare
published studies that have evaluated
phlebotomy methods in rodents
and i'll take a brief look at some of
the published data that's out there for
looking at phlebotomy techniques and
mice and this is just a few of the
papers there's many more
out there i just selected some i thought
would be interesting
but didn't try to make a value judgment
on which ones were included or excluded
and then i'll talk about a paper that we
recently
published at cornell it came in jlass
last year
where we evaluated the impact of a
modified tel tim amputation method for
collecting blood
and mice and just some learning
objectives to keep in mind
throughout the presentation i think it
would be great um
to think about ways that
are things that you need to actually
consider when you're selecting an
appropriate phlebotomy technique so
when you're designing a study think
about how your selection of the
phlebotomy technique can
impact your animals as well as your data
and the people that are collecting that
data
also consider some of the factors that
are associated with a certain bloody
technique
other than just the site of location
that you choose to collect blood from
that can determine the impact that that
method will have on the animal's
perceived pain and distress
also to consider the methods that we
have available for assessing the impact
of that technique on on the mice and
just be aware
of some of the difficulties that exist
as we try to interpret the published
literature that's out there
that's describing these various
phlebotomy techniques and rodents
so as i mentioned there are multiple
sites that exist in the mouse from which
an experimenter can collect blood some
of the more commonly
used i have um depicted here so um lots
of researchers will use the
submandibular vein it's sometimes called
the facial vein
the retro bulbar plexus or sinus is
commonly used in rats and mice
sometimes this will be called
retro-orbital in the literature
the lateral tail vein is also frequently
used as well as the saphenous vein for
blood collection
you can also get blood from mice from
the jugular vein
actually from the sublingual vein and
from tail temp amputation and there's
some other techniques that
i won't have time to mention today such
as a superficial temporal blood
collection
but these are the the main techniques
that i'll discuss at least briefly today
so most of my talk is going to focus on
the impact that the phlebotomy technique
will have
on the animal but it's also important to
realize that the
impact that the phlebotomy method will
also impact
your data and potentially impact the
performer
and since recommendations for phlebotomy
techniques that are proposed either in
working group reports
individual literature papers or even
developed in-house
a researcher really needs to kind of do
their own evaluation
and consider the impacts that the
phlebotomy method will have so now let's
talk about
some of the major factors that will
influence the degree of
impact that if a body method will have
on the mouse
so primarily i think of restraint and
handling is also having a large impact
on the perceived
pain or distress of the animal in
addition to the actual blood sampling
procedure itself
and so restraint varies greatly among
the different techniques
um ranging from full physical restraints
such as a
scruff or the use of a restraint device
to minimal
restraint such as just holding the base
of the tail and some methods actually
also require
anesthesia the length of time that's
required for the different blood
collection methods to get the sample of
blood that you need will also vary
so blood flows at different rates from
the different sites it's going to really
depend on the size of the vessel that's
punctured as well as the blood pressure
at that site
and the length of time is probably going
to have a big impact on certain
parameters that you might measure
particularly if they're impacted by a
stress response
and if that's the case then you would
hopefully get your desired sample
collected before you would have
activation
of the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
axis
which is what's going to be responsible
for changing those stress responsive
hormones
you should also think about the
innervation at the site that will be
punctured
so some areas are going to be more
highly innervated than others and that's
going to impact the acute
pain response that's perceived by the
mice
i also think it's important to consider
the physical use of the anatomic site
that's going to be
be punctured so for instance with the
submandibular or the facial vein
phlebotomy if that causes
tissue damage the mascaratory muscles as
the mice are chewing
post procedure they might experience
discomfort you could also think about
the saphenous vein
if there's some tissue trauma in the leg
that might cause discomfort during
ambulation
so it's important to think what the mice
may also use that site
for it's also important to consider
the risk of secondary injury so we'll
continue to talk about this
um as we mentioned these specific um
phlebotomy options
but there are a lot of reports in the
literature that using the retro
orbital or retro bulbar method has
significant risk for injury to the globe
to the herdarian gland
as kind of i just mentioned using the
submandibular or the facial vein
um that site's very close to other
important anatomic structures such as
the ear canal the temporal mandibular
joint the
facial nerve the mascaratory muscles so
just thinking about what is the risk
for potential injuries to other
structures particularly if
the first attempt at the phlebotomy
method might have gone off target
and it's also important to consider how
the preparation of the site can impact
the animal even for the same
um anatomic site you'll read that
reports vary in how they prepare the
site so
sometimes when you're reading a report
that's looked at tail vein
incision or tubing puncture they might
mention
warming the tail ahead of time for
vasodilation um
some techniques that describe saphenous
venipuncture they shave the site or they
apply alcohol
um and others uh do do no prep so the
amount of just manipulation of that area
might also
impact how the animal perceives the
stress of the procedure
so now that we've talked about some of
the things that can impact um
how how the animal perceives the
procedure even independent of the
location
let's talk about some of the ways that
we can actually assess as an
investigator
or a researcher um the impact that the
method we could choose
would have on the animal so i've divided
these into
looking at physiological parameters and
behavioral parameters
and it's important to measure more than
one parameter and i also wanted to make
a note that
we don't really have a way to weight the
relative importance
of any changes that we might find so you
might find that one technique
causes a change in parameter a but not b
and another technique
causes a change in parameter b but not a
and we don't always know
which one is more important to the mouse
if there's a change in parameter a or b
so i think that's also a reason why it's
important to look at multiple parameters
so when we think of physiological
parameters that we can measure
a list of some i've come up with here
could include you know measuring uh body
weight or food consumption
you could look at reproductive
performance especially if you were doing
some sort of cereal
blood collection and these were in
breeding mice
looking at vitals could be very
informative but it may not be very easy
to do unless the mice have a telemetry
device
often you'll see in papers people have
measured plasma corticosterone and
that's because it's the major
corticosteroid in mice i did want to
point out that if you measure
corticosterone in plasma that's letting
you know sort of about a narrow
window of physiologic time there's other
options you can also measure
corticosterone and
feces or hair and that could give you a
better integration
of stress levels potentially over time
we can also measure blood glucose that's
a really quick
and pretty inexpensive measurement but
hematologic parameters and histologic
histology changes can also be used to
assess the physical impact
of a technique on mice and then we can
also use behavioral parameters
to study the impact of a phlebotomy
method on mice and so two of the more
common ones you'll see
if you look in the literature are the
open field test or the elevated plus
maze
and these are both to unconditioned
response tests
and they evaluate aspects of natural
rodent behavior such as activity
and exploratory behavior as well as
aversion to
the open areas we can also look at
nesting behavior
and grooming just their general activity
their posture
and these things are great because they
can be done sometimes without even you
know moving or disturbing the cage at
all
and you can also potentially record
vocalization
so as i mentioned for most of this
presentation um i'm going to focus
on the impact that the procedure has on
an animal
but i did think it was important to just
point out that the method that you
choose to collect your blood sample can
also impact
your data and so the types of
physiologic responses that the method
can
trigger in the mouse can actually lead
to some pre-analytical variation in your
data by changing some of those
physiologic parameters that we just
talked about
such as corticosterone glucose free
fatty acids and
leukogram and as i mentioned before
if you're worried about these it would
be best if you can get your full sample
collected
before you've had time to activate the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
axis which generally takes several
minutes in rodents and so then a method
that required you know minimal restraint
minimal handling
could achieve the blood collected the
desired volume in a
short amount of time and hopefully did
not require
any administration of analgesia or
anesthesia that's kind of its own
procedure
though might be more favorable if you're
trying to measure
these stress responsive parameters and
potentially mean that you're going to
have less variability
in your data and so just to give you an
example of this
in the literature there are several
reports of how the phlebotomy method
can impact the actual data that you
collect from your blood sample
so in a report by christensen at all
they showed that if you collected blood
from the tail tip
amputation or puncture you had quite a
bit of hemolysis in your sample and that
can change some of your chemistry values
but they did not find hemolysis if the
blood was collected
through retro-orbital bleeding um
in a paper by aslan at all they showed
that you would get a difference in your
glucose sample whether or not you took
blood
from the tail vein versus the saphenous
vein but they didn't find
actually any differences in hemolysis
from blood collected at those two sites
abbaten it all showed that hematology
white blood cell parameters can be
different based on whether or not the
blood was collected from the saphenous
vein where the white blood cell counts
were lower
than if they were collected from the
tail tip
and fernandez it all showed that
multiple
chemistry parameters can be different
whether or not blood was obtained from
the submandibular vein versus the
retro-orbital plexus
so these are just a few examples and as
i mentioned for most the talk we'll talk
about how
the phlebotomy choice will impact the
animal but it is also
important to know that it could impact
your data and maybe you should do a
pilot study first just to make sure
that that sample collection site will be
what's most uh
optimal for the parameters that you're
going to measure
i also wanted to touch briefly before we
move into more about the impact on the
animal
about how your phlebotomy choice can
impact the people that are responsible
for collecting the data
and how that person also can impact the
success of the method
so certainly uh the level that's uh of
stress that's perceived by the person
who's responsible for collecting these
very precious samples
can be different based on the technique
that they're expected to master and be
successful at
and the different phlebotomy techniques
they vary and how feasible they are and
the amount of training required so some
of these techniques require
um you know using just anatomic
landmarks to do a blind puncture where
you can't see the vessel that's your
target
some of them require maybe holding the
animal in a more difficult position
um and so some of these can be more or
less stressful as perceived by the
person who's going to have to be
actually
doing this and on the flip side
the skill of the performer can also
impact um the success of the full body
method
differentially based on on methods so
what i mean by that
i'll show you an example here there's
several reports like this in the
literature
but this paper um by avitan it all
compared the
impact of the expertise of the performer
on plasma corticosterone
response in using two different methods
so
they looked at saphenous venipuncture
and tail tip
amputation and so here on the left in a
we're looking at
um saphenous venipuncture and you can
see that the plasma corticosterone was
significantly higher
in mice that had blood drawn from a
novice
phlebotomist versus mice that had blood
drawn from an experienced phlebotomist
and then contrast on the right and in b
you can see that there was no uh
statistically significant difference in
the plasma corticosterone of mice that
had blood collected via
novice or experienced phlebotomists via
the tail tip
technique so this suggests that at least
the animal's perceived stress response
with bug was collected um via the
saphenous puncture was dependent on the
skill of the phlebotomist
but not in the mice that had blood drawn
from the tail tint amputation
so potentially um you know you you can
kind of get away with a little bit less
skill and not have an
impact on the perceived stress by the
mice with some techniques than others
which makes sense if some techniques are
just harder to perform and be successful
at
than others so now that we've discussed
how the phlebotomy method
can impact the steady animal and the
data as well as the performer
and some of the ways that we can assess
the impact on the animals
let's now talk about some of the
difficulties that exist as we're trying
to
read and interpret the literature that's
out there that's looked at um phlebotomy
methods and mice
there are several difficulties that
exist when you're trying as
you know someone who's interested in
either animal welfare or just picking
the right correct
uh or the most appropriate phobotomy
method for your study and you're out
there reading these papers
and the main one i've already touched on
and that's the techniques
differ blood collection even from the
same site so as i mentioned
um for tail vein incision there will be
some reports that talk about
using a restraint device heating the
tail ahead of time sometimes
the blood is collected over up to eight
minutes i found and run report by
tail incision versus others um would use
tele-incision with very minimal
restraint and get the blood in a much
quicker fashion
some people use anesthesia for the same
technique that others wouldn't
and so this makes it very difficult when
you want to compare the impact across
studies if the whole
sort of preparation and procedure of the
animals varies so much
when researchers designed these studies
to assess the impact on animal welfare
of these different blood collection
techniques they generally have to choose
whether they want to control
for either the volume of blood that they
collect which could impact
the mouse or the amount of time it takes
to get the blood sample we mentioned
this before you know blood's going to
flow at different rates from the
different anatomic sites
so it's it's very difficult to control
for both um so you need to keep that
into
account um sometimes you know
you might get a whole lot less blood
from one mouse than another in the same
amount of time and
the investigators cannot usually control
for both
i also noticed when i was trying to do a
liter
literature search on these phlebotomy
method papers that
often one phlebotomy technique would be
compared to another
or to several others without the use of
an actual control or
sham you know a handled only group and i
think it's important to consider
if you're going to design an experiment
that evaluates the impact
of a phlebotomy method on mice um to con
to include a sham group because that
provides potentially valuable
information
um regarding the potential benefit or a
lack of a benefit
of providing anesthesia or analgesia so
if your
phlebotomy group doesn't behave any
differently in
the physiologic and behavioral metrics
of pain or distress that you measure
than a sham only group then that likely
suggests that providing analgesia or
anesthesia
is not really going to offer a welfare
benefit in that case
okay so now that we've discussed some of
the difficulties and in trying to
glean information from the studies that
are out there on phlebotomy
i'm just going to talk about some of the
the main common methods
and give some of the very broad general
characteristics
about these common techniques and then
i'll go into some of the select
studies that evaluated them
so retro bulbar or often i said it's
referred to as retro-orbital phlebotomy
technique
it generally is described as using a
capillary tube
to go at either the medial or lateral
campus of the eye i've seen both
reported
some institutions will require that mice
be anesthetized for this
procedure you can get large volumes of
blood uh
quite quickly using this procedure some
institutions will repeat
will restrict the number of um serial
samples that can be collected from the
same
eye um there is potential for damage to
the globe and the hardarian gland and
that's that's well documented in the
literature
and is usually cited as one of the main
disadvantages of this technique
there is a potential for excessive
hemorrhage
and this method just is not always
pleasing aesthetically
to some performers the lateral tail vein
uh is another very common technique and
as i've mentioned before the restraint
can vary so in this picture
you can see they're employing a
restraint device um other people will
just minimally
hold sort of the base of the tail and
allow the mouse to have kind of freedom
of movement
you can achieve large volumes with a
lateral tail vein
but it will take a little bit longer and
often you're going to sort of be milking
the tail and kind of collecting drop by
drop
it can be performed serially and if the
serial samples are collected
close enough together in time you can
often just disrupt the clot
to still be able to collect a sample
this method has the advantage
that it's not near other important
anatomic structures or tissues
and the tail vein is often visible it
may be a little harder to see in
pigmented mice
and if there's any excessive bleeding
you would be able to see that as well
the saphenous vein is also reported in
the the literature
um you can um see
varied uh ways of holding the mice some
people will actually just hold them in
their hands other people
do use a restraint device but usually
they'll describe performing some kind of
vessel occlusion proximal to the site
you want to collect the sample
you can get large volumes from the
saphenous relatively quickly
it can be used for cereal blood
collection um it is reported that
saphenous vein collection can cause
tissue trauma
at the site it does have the advantage
though that the target is visible
and then paper will vary in how they
describe the preparation of the site as
i've mentioned before
so some papers describe shaving others
don't or
maybe applying alcohol to help you see
the vein
but obviously those might impact a level
of stress that's going to be perceived
by the animal
the submandibular vein collection it's
often called facial vein i might use
them
interchangeably it's also commonly done
it does require
um full restraint which is usually just
manual restraint with scruffing like
what you can see in the picture
um there are some reports though that
actually recommend anesthesia while
others say that anesthesia
provides uh no improvement in in welfare
indicators
you can definitely get large volumes
from the submandibular vein
quickly and it can be done serially but
as i've mentioned a few times it is near
other
very important structures um in the face
so
you know you're close to the facial
nerve the ear canal tempur-mandibular
joint those masculine muscles
and their salivary glands and lymph
nodes sort of all in that same area um
one of the
main disadvantages i think is that
you're relying on anatomic
landmarks and you don't have a visible
target for what you're trying to
puncture
um and so you can get severe uh
histologic damage and that's that's in
several um
independent reports you can also
get blood from the jugular vein in mice
and reports vary some describe doing
this in a wake mice with full
physical restraint and other reports
describe doing this in anesthetized mice
you can get large volumes from the
jugular again very quickly
and it can be used serially but there is
a potential for damage to surrounding
tissue
and the potential for for hemorrhage
so um now that i've talked about uh some
of
these common techniques i'm just going
to present a paper that actually
compared these five
um common techniques by sciadol that
came out in a 2015
lab animal paper and as i go through
some of the literature that i've
selected
to present today i've made a table so i
can try to give you information
regarding
the type of restraint that was used the
instrument that was used
whether or not they prepped the site how
long it took them to collect
their sample the volume of the sample
that they took and any information they
provide on whether or not serial samples
were collected because i do think as
you're reading these papers it's really
important to try to pull that out
so in this 2015 paper that i mentioned
they compared
um retro bulbar
phlebotomy either with a thick capillary
tube
in awake mice or retro bulbar phlebotomy
using a thin capillary tube and mice
that were actually anesthetized
to tail vein collection in which they
used a restraint device
saphenous vein collection again in which
they used a restraint device
to some mandibular vein where they um
scruffed the mice um
some manual restraint and as well they
also included a jugular vein group
and those mice were anesthetized for
jugular vein phlebotomy
um so i've listed here the instruments
that they have used
also note they did prepare the tail vein
group by putting the their cage under a
red light for 10 minutes
um in this paper they chose to control
for the volume of blood they collected
so they collected approximately 75
microliters um for all of the techniques
and if you look at the duration of time
they they were actually great in
reporting um
the duration of the entire procedure
which was you know from removing that
mouse from its cage
and also just the length of time it took
to collect the blood alone
so you can see that um the retro bulbar
um method in awake mice uh was the
shortest length of the procedure
um and if we look at the anestheti or
anesthetized
procedures um those took uh quite a bit
longer
so what they did to actually then
measure corticosterone they
they took blood from one mouth from each
cage for six days
um via the retro bulbar technique and
they average the corticosterone value
and they call that their baseline
and then they performed this phlebotomy
technique on these these
six listed here 15 minutes after they
performed that technique
they went back and drew a second sample
through the retro bull bar method
and it's that sample in which they
measured the corticosterone so the data
i'm going to show you about
corticosteroid didn't actually come
from blood that was collected by one of
this these six techniques
but rather from blood that was 15
minutes after that technique
so hopefully then able to assess the
stress response
post hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
access so they gave that time to kick in
and then they tried to measure the
stress response associated with these
six different techniques
so this paper by sciatal showed that
retro bulbar phlebotomy may actually
cause
less physiologic and behavioral changes
than the facial vein or submandibular
vein
saphenous tail vein and the anesthetized
jug response
or jug phlebotomy so as i
mentioned they measured uh plasma
corticosterone and i'm showing you that
data here
for all of the groups so the baseline on
that sample that was taken
an average for over six days is in the
red
and then um 15 minutes after bleeding um
by the experimental techniques they took
a sample and measure the corticosterone
so you can see that both retro bulbar
a and b had
sort of lower increases in plasma
corticosteroid than some of the other
techniques
but it is important to note that all the
techniques did cause a significant
increase in plasma corticosterone
relative to baseline
they also came up with a scoring system
which i've i've shown you here
for in-cage activity after the
experimental phlebotomy technique
so um with increasing scores um with
increasing activity
and i'm showing you this data here and
so you can see that retro bulbar
phlebotomy was associated with
a high in-page activity after the
procedure
um which is interesting even in the
retro bulbar group that had received
anesthesia
and then i'm not showing you the data
but this side all paper also reports
that retro bulbar
phlebotomized mice had moderate speed
and distance traveled in the open field
and another really interesting thing
that this study did was compare the
anesthetize versus the non-anesthetized
versions of doing a retro
bullbar phlebotomy technique and they
showed that anesthesia was actually
associated with a greater increase
in corticosterone which you can see
again in the data there on the left
this data or this study also compared
using the thin capillary tubes versus
the thick and they showed that in the
retro bull bar phlebotomy performed with
the thin capillary tubes
they actually saw less histologic
changes at the site than they did
in the groups that had saphenous tail
vein or facial vein phlebotomy
so how they did this they looked at
eight indicators
of histologic changes so i've listed
those here things like hemorrhage
um inflammatory cells degenerative
changes to the tissue edema
and they looked in multiple tissue types
and so they calculated this incidence of
histologic changes
and they provided a percent um of the
the total possible score
so um in their scheme there were 128s
possible
for the non-retro bullbar groups and 192
points possible for the retro bulbar
groups
and they looked one hour after phobotomy
as well as three days and
14 days after phlebotomy and you can see
that the retro
bullbar phlebotomy groups particularly
retro bulbar group b that had the thin
capillary tubes
have the the lowest incidence of
histologic changes
um one hour after as well as low
histologic changes three days after
um but it is interesting to note that it
seems like potentially the histology
changes at the tail vein sites and the
tailbone group
may resolve quite quickly so there was
kind of a steep drop
in the percentage of changes um
um in that group from one hour after to
three hours after tail vein phlebotomy
so this cyano paper um found that
lateral tail vein phlebotomy sort of had
intermediate impacts
on physiologic and behavioral responses
so mice that had tailbeing phlebotomy
had a large increase in corticosterone
but they also had high
in-cage activity and high speed and a
large distance traveled in the open
field
um similarly they showed that the
saphenous vein phlebotomy also seemed to
have
kind of a rather intermediate impact on
these uh metrics that they measured
so the saphenous vein phlebotomy group
had a pretty low increase in
corticosterone as you can see
it's the the fourth group here on the
left
but the saphenous thing group had a high
in cage activity which
suggested a minimal impact and a high
speed and large
distance traveled in the open field
the same paper we're still talking about
the psi at all paper um
showed that some mandibular vein
phlebotomy was associated with an
increased um uh incidence of physiologic
and behavioral responses
um versus uh the retro bulbar and the
tail and the saphenous so
um the submandibular or they call it the
facial
group so it's abbreviated fvb was
associated with
large increases in corticosterone so
it's the second to
the last group um here and so that
increase in corticosterone was very
similar to the anesthetized jugular vein
group
and and higher than the other um
phlebotomy methods
and mice that had the facial vein
phlebotomy also had
decreased activity post phlebotomy and
they
tended to move short distances and move
slowly in the open field
um performing again similarly to the
anesthetized
a jugular group um so we kind of just
talked about the anesthetized jugular
group was pretty
similar to the facial group but they did
have the greatest increase in
corticosterone
and again low in cage activity low speed
and distance traveled um in the open
field
but i did want to point out for for
fairness that the impact
of um saphenousane phlebotomy that's
reported in the literature it does vary
by report so similar to this
sort of cyan paper where we found sort
of this intermediate impact of saphenous
um vein phlebotomy um uh
as led at all showed that there was
lower stress
um response after saphenous venipuncture
than after tail vein
blood collection um avitan it all showed
that plasma corticosterone did not
differ over four samples that were taken
in one week
by the saphenous vein but there are
reports such as the
metamatoja report that show that there's
higher stress
after saphenous venipuncture than after
facial vein or tail vein so
again this kind of goes back to what we
talked about with some of the
difficulties impairing these techniques
um this really may depend on whether or
not the animals were restrained a
certain way
how long it took to do the procedure and
whether or not there was any particular
preparation of the site
so just um you know there's other
reports that also evaluate the saphenous
vein but just to kind of
i wanted to make sure that you were
aware that the impact of saphenous vein
kind of
depends on on what paper that you read
similarly the impacts that are
associated with jugular vein phlebotomy
can vary
by steady so in the sciatic paper that
we just looked at they had anesthetized
the mice
for jugular vein collection and those
mice had um
with facial veins some of the most kind
of severe changes in those metrics that
they measured
but there is a paper by shirazaki at all
i think the
date got a little cut off it's supposed
to be 2012
and they actually performed serial
sampling um from the jugular vein and
they showed that it had less
impact on serologic markers of
physiologic stress versus the lateral
tail vein
so they compared
a wake jugular vein collection with
lateral tailbone collection that was
um done with mice in a restraint device
and then they looked at c-reactive
protein and they showed
that actually the um lateral tail vein
group had higher
serious protein which can be a marker of
stress
than the mice that it had blood
collected from the jugular vein and that
the two groups had similar
plasma corticosterone um so again you
know just kind of a
this if you only read this paper you
might get a different view of jugular
vein phlebotomy than if you had only
read
the science paper so it is important to
kind of think about
the whole technique of the method that
is described
this year's acne at all paper they
showed that even with
cereal sampling done once a day for five
days
in their words that there were only
slight hematomas
and damage to the surrounding tissue and
they they show the image
of that here
so now moving on to a different
technique that's not used as commonly
um and that's the sublingual vein
collection
so there are two veins that are running
from the bases to the apex
and unlike in some other species they're
only thick enough for venipuncture
actually uh near the base um
and that's different from in rats and
hamsters where you could you could
puncture
a larger portion of that vessel's length
so sublingual collection is performed
with
a full restraint some reports talk about
using anesthesia
sometimes it requires two performers so
one person would sort of be holding the
mouse another extracting the tongue and
performing the venipuncture
you can get large volumes of blood this
way relatively quickly
um there is a potential risk that the
mouse can aspirate any blood that's left
in the oral cavity
um and there's also the potential that
that blood collection that blood sample
is going to get mixed with saliva
so saliva contains several um enzymes
that actually start the digestive
process so you might be worried about
that as far as
sample quality but there was at least
one paper i found that looked
that um that sublingual blood collection
at least in rats did not seem to impact
amylase activity in the blood sample
that was collected so potentially
that's not a huge concern but one of the
things that i think i would probably be
at least interested in is whether or not
sublingual collection could impact
food intake and mice and that was
actually looked at
by hymen at all in 2010 and they found
that sublingual veins lobotomy was
associated with no change in food
consumption or weight loss
versus some mandibular phlebotomy so
they looked at either group one where
mice had um
the submandibular vein um punctured and
those mice were just manually restrained
group two were mice that had the
subangular submandibular vein punctured
but they were actually fully
anesthetized
and then in group three were mice that
were anesthetized for sublingual
collection
and then they looked at food consumption
um and you can see that
actually so they measured several days
before the phlebotomy and then you can
see what they've indicated they've done
the blood collection
and then measured food consumption for
several days after
and you can see that group three which
was actually the sublingual vein
collection
had higher food consumption than the two
groups that it had some mandibular
phlebotomy
they also looked at histologic changes
and so this is a bit of a busy graph but
again they're divided by the group so
groups one and two were the
submandibular collections and group
three
the sublingual collection and then um as
the
the row titles here on the left you can
see the types of histologic changes that
they were identifying
and uh they were a greater percentage of
mice as well as having
uh more severe histologic changes in the
submandibular group
versus mice that had the sublingual vein
collection
and so then i'll move to the final
technique that i'm going to talk about
today which is uh
modified tail tip amputation so this
technique was first reported
by abattan at all in 2008
and this technique they reported
performing it with minimal restraint so
just holding the base of the tail
you can collect large samples of blood
this way but it will take
longer than some of the other methods so
similar to tailbane
incision you know you're going to kind
of be milking the tail and sort of
collecting
drop by drop as some tissue is actually
removed
it's likely not suitable for cereal
collection in which the samples are
collected over
a broad span of time however if you can
just disrupt the clot that might be
uh just fine it has the advantage that
there's no damage to
surrounding structures and that the
target is very visible and there's very
minimal excessive bleeding
and so we were interested in this
technique because we had an investigator
here who wanted to measure
several stress responsive parameters and
she was very interested in using a
technique that required very minimal
handling and minimal restraint
so we did perform a study here um uh
actually first let me talk to you a
little bit sorry i got ahead
uh of what actually was reported in the
original paper um by avatan at all and
they showed
um that tilted phlebotomy was associated
with fewer behavioral responses
and a similar corticosteroid response as
saphenous venipuncture
so here are the details of how they
perform their study they looked at
that modified tail clip with mineral
restraint to saphenous collection when
mice are placed in a restraint device
and then they looked at these acute
behavioral responses such as pulling
flinching vocalizing
and you can see that the saphenous group
which is on the left column had a higher
incidence of these acute behavioral
responses than the tail
clip group and then they also measured
as i mentioned corticosteroid and they
saw that the two groups the saphenous
and the tail clip
had very similar plasma corticosterone
um so as i mentioned we were interested
in assessing uh this modified tail clip
impact on mice compared to two other
techniques that were commonly used
and one of the other reasons we were
interested in this is because most
institutions have a policy
that regulates tail snipping for
genotyping so
many institutions including ours will
require either analgesia or anesthesia
if you're going to remove the tail tip
for genotyping and mice over 21 days of
age
and we thought it was uh pretty
important to point out that it is a
different technique so usually people
are removing
several you know up to five millimeters
of tail for genotyping
versus we were just removing um as we
can kind of see in the
in the image um the lower image here
just
kind of the very very very distal one or
two millimeters so we thought it might
be important to actually evaluate the
impact
of this technique on mice so we looked
at
either groups that had blood collected
with some mandibular or facial vein as
how we called it an arseti
puncture and they were manually
restrained we also had a tale of an
incision group
and then our tail temperamentation group
and then we included two sham groups
so the sham submandibular group they
were scruffed and handled just like the
facial ring group and we also had a
tail group that was um mentally
restrained on the top of the cage and
had the tail
milk tail kind of milked even though
there was no actual puncture
and we chose to limit the length of time
for the procedures
so the submandibular facial vein group
was actually
it was much quicker to obtain the
maximum volume of blood allowed so so we
went with the
the um by weight calculation
but then for the tail groups and the
sham groups we timed it out
at two minutes of manipulation so just
briefly the timeline of our study
during the procedure we recorded um any
audible or ultrasonic vocalizations and
we also noted acute behaviors
and we then placed mice into a page for
10 minutes
and recorded behaviors such as uh
activity or inactivity and grooming
then mice went into an open field test
for five minutes they then had five
minutes just sort of as a rest period
back in that observation cage
and then they were placed in an elevated
plus maze for five minutes and both of
those behavioral
tests were video recorded my son went
back to their home page
but six hours after phlebotomy and we
moved them to a new page that had a
brand new little cotton nest pad and
they stayed in that cage for four hours
so we could evaluate their nest building
activity
and then roughly 12 hours after
phlebotomy they were euthanized for
histologic
tissue evaluation so
quickly we did find that tail 10th
amputation was very feasible
we found no significant differences in
the volume of blood that was collected
so all of them
allowed us to uh collect the maximum
volume of blood that would be allowed
and gelting amputation had the highest
number
of successful first attempts so all nine
of those mice had success on the on the
first attempt
three of nine tail incision mice had to
have the incision um
uh deep end to get adequate blood flow
and unfortunately we had only four of
twelve of our facial main group mice had
successful phlebotomy
um on the first attempt we didn't detect
any differences in blood glucose between
the three phlebotomy methods
um facial vein abbreviated fv tail tip
amputation
abbreviated ta until vein incision
abbreviated ti
and this likely reflects that um we
didn't we collected our full sample
before activation of the hypothalamic
pituitary axis
adrenal axis um we did find that there
was a significant impact of the
phlebotomy group
on vocalization so specifically the
facial vein and sham facial vein
um group mice produced more audible
vocalizations
and most of the vocalizations actually
were produced during handling during
scruffing
um and so this led us to believe that
this was largely due to the the handling
procedure since it also occurred in the
sham facial group
um and that that type of restraint is
probably very uh stressful
um to the mice um we didn't have any
ultrasonic
vocalizations recorded during any of the
of inactivity in our facial vein group
mice
and so we defined those as periods of 15
seconds or more in which the mice were
largely immobile and so we interpret
this to mean that the procedure the
facial vein procedure was either more
painful or distressful to to
the mice and this is similar to what was
reported in that original science all
paper that i talked to about earlier
where they also had decreased activity
in their facial vein group
i thought this was quite interesting we
did find actually that tail vein
incision
but not tail tip amputation increased
still grooming so mice generally always
sort of groom their head and body more
than their tail anyway so we analyzed
sort of the tail group
separately and we looked at whether or
not mice how many times they groomed
their head their body or their tail
and mice that had the tail incision
groomed their tail more which may
actually be because there's sort of a
wicking effect of the drop of blood sort
of down the tail
um so it could have been that more than
any pain or distress or or both
but importantly the tail tip amputation
group
paid no more attention to their tail
than the sham tail group
and then we didn't find any impact on
body grooming
in the facial vein group and we included
our two sham groups in that as well
um so then in our behavioral tests
looking first at um the open field test
our mice did behave
normally in the open field test so for
rodents that's you know spending more
time on the periphery and less time out
in the open
but we did note a statistically
significant decrease in velocity
actually in our facial vein group and
the open field again that sort of fits
with those periods of inactivity
and it also is consistent with what the
sci at all paper had reported with
decreased activity and the facial vein
group
post phlebotomy um
mice also behaved normally for rodents
and the elevated plus maize they spent
more time in the closed arms but we
didn't find any impact of phlebotomy
group
on elevated plus maze performance and
then we also looked at nest building so
we had a blinded um
score score pictures of the nest the
mice built
in that four hour window that started
six hours after phlebotomy and they
used a modified published score
by deacon at all and you can see that
there was a non-significant trend
towards decreased next comp
nest complexity in our facial vein group
and although this wasn't statistically
significant it might suggest that
potentially because the
facial vein puncture is at the site of
the mastitory muscles maybe those mice
are are less
spending less time sort of chewing and
shredding the nest
and potentially had we done a different
time point or provided different types
of nesting material
um a significant difference may
potentially have showed up
and finally we looked at histology
differences between our groups
um and we did find that the facial vein
puncture resulted in the most severe
histologic changes so i'm showing you
here
in a a more zoomed out transverse
section of the head
so the area of the facial vein is
indicated by the arrow and this was in a
mouse that had no significant
um findings then that box and a is sort
of where we're zoomed in in b
and the arrow head is pointing to some
mild sub q hemorrhage
and a facial vein group mouse and then c
and d
are showing you um sort of progressively
more severe hemorrhage and some facial
vein
group mice that are around some other
important structures such as the
submandibular lymph node and salivary
gland
you can actually even see some red blood
cells that are draining into the sinuses
of the lymph node in d um
so we did find more uh incidences and
more severe histologic changes in our
facial vein group
uh we're looking um in e f
at some histo sections from uh tailbeam
incision mice so in e there are no
significant changes and f
we're seeing some mild uh neutrophil
infiltration
and then in g and h i'm showing you
histosections from mice that had the
tail tip amputation phlebotomy performed
in g you can see that caudal vertebra is
still intact and then h you can see that
the caudal vertebra was actually
transected and in these mice we saw
usually mild fibrin maybe mild
neutrophil infiltration
or just sort of a normal response to any
kind of tissue trauma
we did note ideally that the caudal
vertebra would not be transected but
um due to the sort of overall lack of
response
in the behavior and physiologic
parameters that we measured
and the tilted vampiration group and the
lack of any difference in that tail top
amputation group
and the chamtel group we think that
potentially
this impact is not very significant
on the mic so in summary
we suggest that tail temp amputation is
potentially superior phobotomy method
in terms of animal welfare when suitable
for your steady needs
so again in summary we found that there
was no evidence that tilting amputation
caused
more pain or stress to mice than just a
sham manipulation of their tail
or then two already approved methods and
awake adult mice
um we found that facial gain phlebotomy
may actually be the least desirable of
the three methods in terms of animal
welfare
even though it took less total handling
time so again facial being phlebotomy
was associated
with increased audible vocalizations
increased periods of inactivity
reduced speed and open field tests and
more severe
histologic change and we found no
evidence to suggest that providing
analgesia or anesthesia with tail type
amputation
would be beneficial given the lack of
differences between the tail tip
amputation and sham
groups so i'd like to acknowledge my
co-authors that were on this paper
with me as well as some individuals who
were important
for the data analysis stuff and of
course the cornell university center for
animal resources and education
where i conducted the study as part of
my residency training
and i'll put my summary slide back up
and then i would be happy
to take any questions
thank you so much elizabeth for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question drop
down box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many
as questions as we have time for today
so let's get started
let's see what our audience first
questions are
that are already coming in our first
question is
elizabeth how does tail tip amputation
differ from tail tip biopsy that is
commonly
performed for genotyping
i think that's a great question and as i
mentioned before that's sort of one of
the reasons why we are actually
interested
in performing this study so at our
institution and many others
if tail tips are biopsied um to collect
tissue for genotyping
after the mouse has been weaned so we
say after 21 days
they provide or they're required to
provide analgesia under anesthesia
and that's essentially because at that
age in most strains the caudal vertebrae
have fully ossified and we think that
the procedure is more painful that age
than than before 21 days
um and so when we had investigators here
at cornell they were interested in using
the modified tail tip amputation
technique
um we sort of had concerns as to whether
or not they should provide analgesia
and um but there is actually a large
difference in the degree of tissue
that's transected
so you can take usually up to five
millimeters of tail
for um genotyping but we really were
only just taking that caudal even you
know one millimeter one to two
millimeters
um with the tail temp amputation um and
also
usually the genotyping procedures sort
of performed with some kind of
identification so usually the mice are
picked up and they're scruffed
and we also we're performing only this
minimal handling
and minimal tissue removal so that's why
we wanted uh to more evaluate the impact
that this
kind of modified and and minimal tail
tip amputation technique would have
versus
your kind of traditional tissue removal
for for tail biopsy and genotyping
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members who are asking
questions today and remind them that any
questions that aren't answered today
elizabeth is more than welcome to answer
via email
we have one more question coming in why
wouldn't providing
analgesia be a safe default when
performing
a phlebotomy i think that is a great
question and sort of i think
often we think you know we're doing good
by by doing that
um and it's sort of our our desire to
just give the analgesia sort of as a
as a default just assuming that
something is painful and that's going to
be
of a benefit but um most of the time
providing analgesia such as giving a
ketoprofen or meloxicam or some other
nonsteroidal anti-inflammatory
is going to be another procedural event
for the mouse so it's an additional
handling procedure it's it's scruffing
the mouse restraining the mouse
and then giving it another needle
injection to actually provide
provide that drug um and actually if
you're going to usually give that drug
long enough to kick in
you would have to do that well enough in
advance of your your blood collection
procedure for those drugs to really be
on board
and then unfortunately that handling
impact and the stress that that caused
the animal may impact your data
collection what you're measuring in your
blood sample
and truly um the benefit provided by
that analgesia
may not outweigh the additional stress
that's caused by the mouse and that
additional handling and
an administration procedure so that kind
of goes back to where i think it's
really important to have these sham only
or handled only groups
in these studies that look at the impact
of phlebotomy
because if you see no difference between
a method and a sham only group
then likely providing analgesia is not
going to improve the welfare and may
actually cause
increased stress because now you've
handled the mice uh twice
wonderful thank you and thank you very
much for your presentation today
and for your important research do you
have any closing remarks you'd like to
share
with the audience before we close today
i just thank you guys for listening i
think that this is a really
important topic that we keep evaluating
especially
now as we get better and better metrics
to be able to evaluate our impact on
mice
so i think that there's still a lot out
there that we can we can learn so i
encourage other people to continue to
conduct these
uh well-designed studies to evaluate the
impacts of phlebotomy on mice that we
can continue to just improve our
techniques
both to improve our our data and also to
have
less impact on animal welfare